[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct on est avec
vous c'est figaro live et on attend vos
points de vue avant un week-end bien sûr
avec le figaro magazine où vous
trouverez un magnifique entretien avec
fabrice luchini et après 24 heures 24
heures après la condamnation de l'auteur
de la gifle contre emmanuel macron alors
question ce soir trouvez vous que cette
peine de quatre mois de prison ferme et
inflige infligée est juste trop lourdes
ou trop légère je vous propose d'en
débattre ce soir avec guillaume guigo un
spécialiste du populisme puisque vous
êtes l'auteur de cette excellente et
c'est sur le fossé entre les élites et
le peuple la pop la pop et du show-biz
ou plus exactement comment les élites
des tests peuple avec une comparaison
historique
c'est vraiment très intéressant et on
n'a de cesse de le recommander à la
lecture et en plus c'est extrêmement
bien écrit merci guillaume de l'avoir
fait et d'être là avec nous ce soir est
avec nous avec vous ce soir l'excellent
ferghana ziari bonsoir et on a hâte de
lire votre prochain livre
donc il devrait paraître en septembre en
s'abonnant reste de la cité et on spoil
le thème un peu oui c'est sur les
questions environnementales show
l'écologie et une défense de la
civilisation industrielle et de la
modernité
pour faire face aux enjeux
environnementaux voilà on se perd en
sans spoiler on pourra dire que c'est
pas trop effectivement à la demande
expresse pas trop décroissant pas trop
un livre qui sera prise et au prochain
parlement d'europe écologie les verts
mieux respirer en tout cas mieux faire
respirer l'économie ça tombe bien
peut-être parce qu'il ya un sujet
connexe qu'on abordera ce soir je vous
propose en tous les cas d'aborder avec
nous c'est de revenir sur la première
tournée européenne de joe biden et
surtout sa croisade contre la chine la
question qu'on se pose c'est est ce que
l'europe et la france doivent s'envoler
comme un seul homme dans le combat que
joe biden mène dans la croisade que joe
biden mène contre la chine
c'est l'autre question qu'on pose sur
twitter etc notre débat que vous propose
d'avoir avec nous ce soir mais d'abord
on vient sur l'homme de la semaine en
tout cas celui qui a marqué ces sept
derniers jours
avec ce geste vous me connaissez il
s'appelle damien tard elle il a été
condamné à quatre mois de prison ferme
et 14 avec sursis
on pose une question donc sur twitter la
peine de quatre mois pour une gifle au
président et l
juste voici ce qu'en pense avant d'en
débattre avec vous avant de lire vos
réponses
voici ce qu'en pense le philosophe
michel onfray qui était l'invité de
radio classique
en partenariat avec le figaro mais là ce
que je découvre c'est quand même que qui
est vraiment deux poids deux mesures sur
la justice aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
deux ans trois ans quatre ans pour voir
votre dossier aboutir si vous fumez des
pétards vous pouvez jeter un oeil
vieille dame juive par la fenêtre
aucun problème parce qu'on peut juger si
en revanche vous met une gifle le
président de l'admical orlin c'est dans
les coins trois jours deux ou trois
jours et puis le soir même vous êtes en
prison
guillaume bigot vous qui êtes un
souverainiste promoteur de la grandeur
de l'état est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est trop où vous trouver comme on
ferait que ce n'est pas normal qu'il a
été il a été aussi vite condamné
en fait on peut qu'on peut tenir les
deux positions ensemble mais insee la
mienne justement c'est à dire que la fin
de vie en même temps non non non c'est
pas du en même temps c'est que on peut
soutenir logiquement une la nécessité
d'une d'une peine ferme de 4 mois qui
semble assez proportionnée parce que
parce que je suis assez sensible et
argument qu'a développé henri guaino
c'est à dire qu'il ya une violence
symbolique très forte
si on porte atteinte d'une certaine
façon à la clé de voûte des institutions
si on porte atteinte
enfin si on est capable de lever la main
sur le président de la république il y à
une sorte de deux d'autorisation
implicite de la violence et de ce genre
de ce genre de geste donc ça il ça
libère quelque chose donc la peine ferme
me paraît indispensable et on sent bien
qu'on est passé d'une sorte de société
du de l'excusé à une société de la
répression une sorte de besoin pénale de
deux mondes pénale parce que souvenez
vous manuel valls
il avait également pris une gifle et
la sanction avait été six mois avec
sursis là c'est treize mois 18 mois ces
quatorze 14 ans avec sursis quatre mois
de prison ferme exactement dont la
prison ferme donc d'un côté on peut tout
à fait soutenir une peine de prison
ferme et par ailleurs pour la même
raison et donc c'est pas du en même
temps c'est pas faire tenir ensemble le
blanc et le noir c'est c'est la même
logique demandé à ce que des actes
beaucoup plus grave que cela soit
réprimé également rapidement et soit
réprimé à la hauteur de ce qu'ils font
le pic pédopsychiatre maurice berger
dans son dernier livre que je recommande
a abondamment enfin il ya énormément d
exemples de cas de violences extrêmes un
déchaînement de violence extrême qui
aboutit non seulement à des coups et
blessures mais à des handicaps à vie et
il y a que d'à peine de prison avec
sursis à la clé donc on voit bien que si
vous l'avez ce décalage est évidemment
choquant donc michel onfray a raison la
justice peut-être faire c'est d'être
fermée elle choisit ses cibles et ses
combats d'une certaine façon fergane est
ce que vous pensez qu'à millau mais
comme michel onfray que dans un certain
sens c'est un peu injuste parce qu'il ya
deux parfois deux poids deux mesures est
ce que le libéral que vous êtes se
réjouit où le libéral que z se réjouit
de la condamnation d'un homme qui se dit
anarchiste proposait finalement
l'incarnation du pouvoir exécutif qui
est la figure de l'arbitraire en tout
cas chez les auteurs que vous chérissez
oui enfin les monarchies généralement
auquel moi en tout cas je me réfère
sondés sont des gens qui sont pacifiques
qui récuse usage de la violence sont pas
des anneaux mist qui glorifie le fait de
s'appeler les anneaux mise c'est ceux
qui refusent la loi
oui toute forme de conventions sociales
et de normes simplement c'est à dire que
la remontée face à un manque de décence
commune élémentaires de la part en plus
d'un militant qui déplore la décadence
de l'occident et de la france est quand
même assez assez cocasse
donc quand à la sévérité de la peine
alors tout dépend des standards auxquels
on se réfère si on se réfère aux
standards de l'ancien régime puisque
apparemment ce monsieur a quand même eu
relire un slogan qui qui qui
qui est n'est pas un cri de guerre
royalistes bon il faut savoir qu'elles
sont à l'époque dans l'argile
il aurait compté ni écartelée donc si on
prend les standards d'ancien régime que
ce jeune homme là affectionne c'est
peut-être un peu trop clément maintenant
c'est vrai que bon moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent qu'il faut réserver la
prison au crime vraiment comment dire
irrécupérable irréparable et j'aurai à
mon avis préféré qu'on lui inflige une
amende de des travaux d'intérêt général
ça aurait été plus proportionnés et je
crois pas qu'il faille à mon avis
utiliser l'argument de la fonction pour
justifier une sévérité particulière
c'est à dire que le fait de juger
quelqu'un est tout simplement
inexcusable que vous soyez présent la
république où le commun des mortels
c'est sûr ne ment pas tolérable c'est à
dire que les gens qui se court qui
argumentent sur le terrain de la
fonction présidentielle sous-entendre
que le commun des mortels finalement on
pourrait giflé le citoyen lambda
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus aisément
il faut simplement je crois a rappelé
que dans 7 et civilisé on est juif le
personnes quelles que soient les
circonstances sauf en cas de légitime
défense mais il signé pas d'agression
caractérisée de la part des milieux
macron donc cet acte doit être condamnée
en tant que tel indépendamment de
l'identité de la personne qui reçoit la
gifle à ce que ce que dit fergane vous
êtes d'accord c'est à dire que quand on
se
on dénonce justement la violence
symbolique comme henri guaino cela
revient à légitimer les agressions
contre conciliables contre le quidam
c'est vrai que l'avocate de damien tard
elle a appelé des notamment le fait que
si emmanuel macron était un citoyen
lambda la peine
laquelle aurait été condamné en tous les
cas la peine qu'on courait dans ce cas
la corée encourus dans ce cas-là damien
tard elle aurait été une simple amende
je suis d'autant moins d'accord qui a
pas de lien de cause à effet mais il ya
que c'est pas le lien en tout cas que
décrit fait regarde c'est à dire c'est
le lien inverse je m'explique la
politique le symbole de la politique
la dimension symbolique de la politique
vise à neutraliser la violence le
mécanisme des élections c'est expurgé la
violence qui est au coeur de chacun de
nous pour la rendre symbolique et donc
on institue comme ça des des autorités
qui à qui on confie en plus le monopole
de la violence légitime donc être
capable de gifler la clé de voûte des
institutions la personne qui garantit en
fait qui est qui symbolise le fait que
l'état a le monopole de cette violence
c'est mettre à bas d'une certaine façon
alors symboliquement pas réellement mais
né au moins symboliquement et je pense
que le contexte on doit tenir compte du
compte elle mettre à bas symboliquement
ben oui parce que on est dans une époque
de dames en volume en quoi c'est mettre
à bas symboliquement l'ordre social
l'ordre politique là d'une certaine
façon le fait que l'état prive les
citoyens de recourir à la violence même
si cette violence là je suis bien
d'accord avec vous elle n'est pas l est
pas elle n'a pas fait couler le sang
c'est juste une humiliation mais ça
humilie la fonction symbolique ça
l'humilie la démocratie et donc ça dans
une époque où l'ensauvagement galope
je trouve qu'ils avaient vraiment besoin
de marquer une limite 750 euros damende
ainsi effectivement ce n'était pas la
présence d'un public qui aurait été un
salon le coup on peut aussi juger que
les lois pénales
droit commun sont beaucoup trop clémente
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui gifle une
personne sans aucune raison dans la rue
je trouve que 750 euros damende s'était
passé pour le coup mais pas parce que
cette personne serait le président la
république où que ce soit mais parce que
l'acte de gifler un être humain de
manière complètement arbitraires dit
simplement pas acceptables donc c'est
sur ce terrain là à mon avis qu'il
faudra argumenté plus que le fait
d'essayer d'introduire une espèce
d'asymétrie comme si emmanuel macron
était un monarque ou un dieu alors on
parle beaucoup de désacralisation de la
fonction que moi je trouve ça assez
curieux parce que bon mois au risque
d'en décevoir certains je suis pas un dc
de la religion civile ni au public elle
je suis pas croyant en matière de
république je considère que l'état est
un prestataire et non pas un dieu auquel
ils ont doit obéissance mais ça ne
justifie pas pour autant qu'on s'en
prenne aux individus indépendamment du
caractère institutionnel de la et
simplement l'acte de gifler un individu
est tout simplement illégitime et mérite
une répression appropriées
proportionnées
mais parce que simplement ne pas giflé
c'est la première des choses à faire
dans un set et civilisé c'est tout bas
le sacré c'est ce qui nous dépasse le
sacré sedo ce dont on hérite ce qu'on
transmet et le sacré ça forcément avoir
pas nécessairement avec la religion des
religions révélées mais ça tout à fait à
voir avec la vie et la mort c'est à dire
que le premier rite sacré
anthropologiquement c'est le fait
d'enterrer or je vous rappelle que le le
président de la république l'état tout
état de la cité à l'état nation a le
mode a le pouvoir de tuer c'est la
raison pour laquelle même les policiers
ont une arme et c'est la raison pour
laquelle des hommes peuvent être
envoyées sur le champ de bataille au
mali et ailleurs et donné leur vie et
dont qu'on leur témoigne d'ailleurs
d'une forme de de respect sacré les
monuments aux morts etc
donc c'est faux de dire que la politique
où l'état tout est à toute politique
d'ailleurs dès le démarrage
un lien avec le sacré alors heureusement
on est dans une civilisation
judéo-chrétienne on a dissocié le
politique du religieux et je suis bien
d'accord avec ça que je ne veux pas non
plus d'un culte de l'état
mais ce n'est pas pour ses pas pour
c'est pas parce que l'état est laïque
qu'il n'y a pas une forme de sacré
laïque
on aimerait avoir une justice aussi
rapide et forte pour les policiers
agressés nous dit nicole il ya un
certain nombre de messages qui sont 2
dans cette danse est teneur sur youtube
tout à l'heure général escape avant le
début de l'émission on disait
démonstration parfaite que la justice
est efficace il ironisé rapide sévère et
exemplaire quand il s'agit de protéger
leurs élites
en revanche le citoyen victime de
l'ensauvagement ou qui a son logement
squatté il peut toujours courir avant
d'avoir une bassline sujet même d'avoir
une peine pareil moi j'entends tout à
fait ces arguments là qui sont donnés
par les internautes depuis le début de
l'émission et qu'on peut entendre depuis
le prononcé de cette peine mais est ce
que finalement c'était pas à tout le
moins qu'il y ait une condamnation cette
condamnation ferme parce que s'il n'y
avait pas eu ça alors effectivement on
dit que déjà c'est grave que quand on
poursuit des quand il ya des gens qui
s'attaquent à des policiers ils ne sont
pas bien poursuivie ou que 750 euros
damende pour une simple gifle c'est
c'est beaucoup trop clément alors si
effectivement il n'y a pas eu de fermeté
vis-à-vis de ça parce que c'est pas un
coup d'arrêt aussi quand même c'est
totalement un coup d'arrêt je pense
qu'il ya quand même une confusion
aujourd'hui entre la notion de justice
et la notion de morale la justice rendue
dans un état c'est destiné à limiter au
maximum la violence en tout cas l'a vu
la justice pénale à la réduire à sa
portion congrue et sa vie au moindre mal
ça ne vise pas aux biens donc
effectivement moralement c'est
inéquitable j'entends cet argument d'un
point de vue individuel
du point de vue collectif et du point de
vue de la société je pense que ça va
dans le bon sens effectivement de ce
cran d'arrêt et ce refoulement de la
violence un dernier point peut-être
fergane peut-être alors ce qui est ce
que c'est pas
chaud ce qui n'est pas choquant
peut-être de nature à vous choqué ce
sont les peines complémentaires auxquels
elle a été condamnée damien tard elle
notamment
il se voit condamné à recevoir des soins
psychologiques
ah oui c'est vrai que cette
psychiatrisation effectivement du
délinquant je ne vois pas très bien
l'intérêt parce qu'on a ni du coup le
principe de responsabilité pénale c'est
à dire que le fait l'intérêt de
condamner une personne dans un état de
droit c'est con on estime que cette
personne est en pleine possession de son
libre arbitre et donc on peut lui
demander des comptes sur sur ce qu'elle
peut faire de mal donc si on lui
prescrit des des soins psychologiques on
sous-entend finalement que cette
personne n'était pas saine d'esprit et
donc on l'a déresponsabilise dans une
certaine mesure effectivement de ce
qu'elle a fait donc non ce qui me choque
davantage ce qui me concerne c'est la
remarque qui a été fait par un des
internautes c'est qu'on aurait aimé
on aimerait que la justice soit aussi
efficace quand il s'agit de réprimer la
délinquance du quotidien on a assisté il
ya pas longtemps
oui oui on a assisté il ya pas longtemps
à l'ouverture du procès de la jeune
fille l'a en tout cas d'aidé de ce qu'il
est et qui les harcèlent bon ben voilà
un exemple on aimerait bien que une q
que la justice soit une efficacité telle
qu'une jeune fille ne soit pas contraint
de se cacher pour avoir tenu des propos
un peu crus contre une religion
donc cette la rapidité du jugement ne me
choque absolument pas en revanche c'est
effectivement cette rapidité gagnerait à
être être tout simplement appliqué pour
les affaires de délinquance les plus les
plus courantes
je vous donne la parole en vous
rappelant la question con
vous posez sur twitter regardez les
réponses à cette question
la peine de quatre mois de prison pour
une gifle au président est elle juste et
vous répondez oui c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que vous êtes assez
partagés finalement oui à 58%
mais c'est pas un oui écrasant je vous
donne encore la parole à olap c'est sans
doute une peine juste mais il faut
étendre cette sévérité à toutes les
violences
nicole 06 encore trois ans suppression
de ses droits y compris parentaux c'est
plus qu'exagéré c'est votre point de vue
ça aussi guillaume je trouve que ce qui
est très très intéressant cette question
de la psychiatrisation parce que
finalement si on s'arrête un instant sur
cette psychiatre isation d'abord ça fait
un peu penser à l'union soviétique c'est
sûr ça veut dire que en fait tout acte
de violence partie des violences
politiques relèverait en fait d'une
perte de d'une paire de rationalité et
de d'une manifestation de démence de
folie de pâtes serez pathologique en
fait voilà c'est ça oui c'est ça l'idée
et on nous ressort ça à chaque fois dès
qu'il y à du djihad libre et voilà on
vous dit que c'est de la pathologie donc
alors à ce compte là effectivement
pendant une fois en attendant de voir le
signal est comme ça faisait exactement 1
vendredi à vendredi sans attentat c'est
assez rare ces derniers temps vendredi
donc sans pathologie et donc c'est très
intéressant pourquoi parce que c'est
l'idée finalement c'est un fantasme
je pense profond que l'on pourrait
extirper la violence du coeur de l'homme
c'est à dire qu'en réalité la norme ce
serait la non violence et la société
rend les gens méchants les préjugés
rendent les gens méchants construisons
des supermarchés créons la prospérité et
on supprimera la violence et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que je vous
signale que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a on à cesser de réprimer
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
prononcé des peines avec sursis puis des
rappels à la loi puis face à des gens
qui rendent des gens handicapés on leur
dit vous allez faire un stage de
citoyenneté pour apprendre à être gentil
ou alors on va vous donner des
médicaments etc bon bref on considérons
que c'est une sorte de défiance et que
s'ils voient le monde tel qu'il est ils
ne seront plus les causes de cette
violence seront éteintes évidemment
c'est une très très grande naïveté
c'est d'une naïveté confondante
voire même je vous revois ce livre de
gide les caves du vatican l'acte gratuit
tous les lycéens terminale on a pris ça
en philosophie c'est le mal dans sa vie
c'est aussi un acte de liberté
finalement de commettre deux mâles de
s'éloigner du bien donc c'est à dire il
ya quelque chose dans la négation de la
liberté individuelle dans le fait de
refuser de refouler qu'il y a le que le
mal existe que les gens peuvent
volontairement de faire le mal un
dernier point une dernière réaction on a
bien compris et on relira donc à profit
les caves du vatican de gide macron
lui-même a désacralisé la fonction
estime axel ça c'est un autre débat et
qu'on avait eu justement mardi en
commentant cet incident à tain
l'hermitage je vous propose de
passé à deuxième thème d'actualité sans
transition comment disait au 20e siècle
doit-on absolument s'opposer à la chine
à la suite des états unis d'amérique
c'est une question quand vous pose alors
que joe biden en a tendu les bras
ouverts par les européens entament une
tournée sur le vieux continent et qu'il
promet de renouer les liens vous voyez
en ces termes en ce moment d'incertitude
mondiale alors que le monde est toujours
aux prises avec une pandémie unique en
son genre
ce voyage a pour but de concrétiser
l'engagement renouvelé de l'amérique
envers ses alliés est de démontrer la
capacité des démocraties à relever les
défis à dissuader les menaces de cette
nouvelle ère voici comment emmanuel
macron lui voit les choses et annonça
comment vont se passer selon lui
aimerait que les relations se passe
selon lui avec les états unis d'amérique
présidée par jean van hamme je me
félicite du réengagement américain dans
le concert des nations
et dans cette ce multi latérale isme
coopératif est pour moi la clé c'est que
les européens restent unis et attentifs
à leur souveraineté commune et c'est que
nous puissions avoir aussi une autre
voie communauté de valeurs mais
indépendance quand il s'agit de notre
stratégie à l'égard de la chine
stratégie à l'égard de nos voisins qu'il
s'agisse de la russie ou la turquie
est ce que vous trouvez fergane qu
emmanuel macron a raison ou est-ce que
vous deux vous pensez qu'ils devraient
faire plus que ce commune avec le
président américain contre la chine je
pense que adresse je crois qu'il faut
dissocier le combat contre la chine et
le combat contre le parti communiste
chinois ce sont deux choses différentes
à dire que moi je n'ai pas envie que
notre civilisation partent en guerre
contre un peuple
la chine qui est un peuple tout à fait
innocent et qui est même l'otage
finalement du parti communiste chinois
qui est l'une des plus vastes
d'organisations criminelles aujourd'hui
qui existent sur la terre et c'est comme
ça je crois qu'il faut présenter cette
organisation ce n'est pas un régime
politique anodin c'est un régime
politique criminelle qui dans un monde
normal et bien verrait tous ses membres
passée 1-1 devant une cour pénale
internationale ohr police politiquement
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas possible parce
que les considérations géopolitiques
font qu'on peut pas se permettre de
faire cela aujourd'hui donc on est
obligé de d'interagir avec ce régime
criminel mais je crois que comme au
temps de la guerre froide
eh bien il faut finalement agir de sorte
à affaiblir finalement ce parti
communiste quitte à créer une coalition
finalement des pays occidentaux et des
pays libéraux une manière générale qui
se reconnaissent dans les idéaux
libéraux qui on partage l'objectif
effectivement de lutter contre un régime
totalitaire en fait un arrêt au stand
sur déjà sur cette idée donc d'affaiblir
le parti communiste chinois avec une
coalition de pays occidentaux et de
démocratie dans votre livre rouge
guillaume bigot justement vous vous
attaquez dont je n'ose comme ça le livre
de guillaume bigot vous attaquez
justement à ce divorce entre le peuple
et les élites alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette analyse et de cette
conviction de férial d'essayer justement
de dissocier le peuple chinois de son
d'élite qui le dirige ce que vous pensez
également que le parti communiste
chinois prend ce peuple en otage
c'est une question qui est l'étrangère
je pense
à l' opposition diplomatique que la
france devrait prendre à l'égard de
cette croisade américaine
finalement qui était à la fois alors a
escalé anti chinoises ou est ce qu'elle
est dirigée contre le parti communiste
chinois
je rappelle qu'en france on reconnaît on
reconnaît les états pas les régimes on
peut pas se substituer aux chinois pour
dire aux chinois quel est le régime
qu'ils devraient adopter
nous nous en tant que français et je
partage bien sûr totalement la
conviction de fair game c'est à dire je
pense que c'est un régime
d'après nos standards qui paraît quand
même assez plus que critiquable mais
c'est aux chinois de régler ça et on
sait bien que la démocratie à coups de
bombes ou à coups de missiles l'imposé
ça ne fonctionne pas la démocratie c'est
pas une plante en pot ou elle doit
s'enraciner profondément c'est parce que
sinon je comprends mais on peut pas si
vous les lie alcon une confusion entre
la politique étrangère la politique
extérieure la politique diplomatique
juger là qu'ils ont des prises de
position de la chine diplomatiques
militaires voire d'ailleurs commercial
avec savoir quel est le meilleur régime
pour les chinois parce que souvent
entendu je comprends bien il fallait
dissocier les chinois de leurs régimes
et enfin en attendant c'est aux chinois
de décider quel quel régime il va la
voir et c'est pas la politique étrangère
des occidentaux qui doit régler cette
question ce serait ce serait à mon avis
très contre-productif disons que le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que les
chinois complètement dépossédé de la
faculté de choisir finalement le région
dans laquelle ils veulent vivre non
d'approché dur pour eux mais je pense
que si il faut si on peut aider à
moindre coût je suis d'accord qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'aller
d'aller bombarder un une quelconque
région mais si on peut à moindre coût
tentez finalement de remporter ce combat
idéologique ce n'est pas un combat
militaire parce que personne n'a intérêt
à une confrontation militaire directe
avec avec la chine ni pékin ni
washington ni les européens ne veulent
la guerre ce serait complètement
contre-productif au regard des coûts de
la guerre des interdépendances
commercial etc
en revanche je crois qu'il faut
reconnaître que quelque part la guerre
froide finalement qui a rythmé le xxème
siècle n'est pas terminée qu'on est
encore aujourd'hui dans un monde
multipolaire avec des civilisations
rival sur le plan idéologique sur le
plan des principes et que nous
occidentaux gagnerions à être beaucoup
plus ferme sur sur nos valeurs et à
espérer un jour quel triomphe
même si ça doit prendre pas mal de temps
mais ça implique
d'où le fait que je dise qu'il faille
dissocier le régime politique chinois de
la chine est bien d'agir intelligemment
avec les chinois de ne pas par exemple
s'engouffrer dans une espèce de spirale
de restriction d'une guerre commerciale
comme trump l'avait lavé l'avait initié
je crois que ce serait contre-productif
y compris du point de vue géopolitique
pourquoi parce que bon ça a marché parce
que le commerce c'est plus qu'une
affaire de gros sous c'est aussi le
libre échange des idées prenez l'exemple
l'histoire du japon par exemple qu'est
ce qui fait que le japon est aujourd'hui
dans le camp occidental c'est pendant
pendant très longtemps les japonais ont
quand on dire entretenu des relations
commerciales avec les européens avec les
néerlandais ce qui leur a permis au
cours du xviie siècle d'importer comme
ça la culture occidentale passé il était
épris d'une certaine curiosité qui fait
que en plusieurs siècles ils se sont
ensuite moderniser et à occidentaliser
donc c'est en l'approfondissant
finalement les biens commerciaux avec
les peuples qui nous entourent qui fait
que nous occidentaux on peut exporter
nos valeurs d'où je crois à la nécessité
de mener une
politique étrangère intelligente qui ne
soit pas répressive à l'égard du peuple
chinois
sans pour autant négliger la nécessité
de voir un jour le régime politique
chinois voudraient le parti communiste
chinois s'écrouler bon équilibre juste
comprendre un point fergane sur votre
dans votre dans l'autre point de vue en
gros vous dites qu'il faut faire tout
pour tout en mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que le parti communiste chinois de
toutes en panne à partir d'écrits de la
chine
mais enfin même comme m dirigée par le
parti communiste chinois il faut pas
faire de guerre commerciale avec la
chine c'est ça votre peau nue au bafa de
guerre commercer avec la chine parce que
ce serait appauvrir tout le monde et ce
serait contreproductive d'un point de
vue politique puisse avoir une fois le
but c'est bien que les idéologies
aujourd'hui la chine prospère grâce à un
conditionnement par le parti communiste
chinois prospère grâce à un
conditionnement idéologique très
strictes et fait effectivement que la
population est sous l'emprise d'une
propagande permanente donc le but c'est
de briser ce conditionnement idéologique
par justement des liens commerciaux
toujours plus ouvert avec les signatures
que le monde libre comme on l'appelait
jadis hockey compris guillaume à ce que
je me trompe si je vous dis que vous
avez un positionnement complètement
inverse de fer en faveur du parti
communiste chinois ou à la marge mais
par contre il faut une guerre
commerciale avec la chine
ben c'est presque ça c'est presque ça
parce que bon je vais j'ai un peu
modérer ce que j'ai tout à l'heure il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas une déconnexion
complète entre disons
la puissance de rayonnement d'un régime
et le fait que ce régime puisse marquer
des points et avancer ses pions sur
l'échiquier géopolitique
évidemment quand hitler avance en sarre
et il s'empare de la tchécoslovaquie
évidemment ça fait ça renforce son
pouvoir et ça renforce son régime
si demain sans coup férir pékin s'empare
de taipei et de taïwan
bah ça va pas affaiblir toutes choses
égales par ailleurs le régime communiste
chinois ça on est bien d'accord
et d'une certaine façon ça montrera à la
face du monde que les états unis et à
travers les états unis oui la démocratie
occidentale donc je pense que ça peut
avoir une caisse de résonance donc
j'apporte une sorte de de moderato pour
le reste oui je suis persuadé que là
quand on met la pression sur les sur les
sur la chine
et quoi qu'on en dise ça met également
la pression sur les chinois parce que le
régime chinois utilisent cette
propagande que ce soit la question des
ouïgours qu'elle soit la question du
tibet en fait la population chinoise que
je connais un peu pas le parti
communiste les gens à la base sont
extrêmement nationaliste et chauvin donc
ça fait flamber le nationalisme chinois
et cela n'affaiblit pas du tout le
régime
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
et par ailleurs oui je pense que si on
veut de manière graduelle faire évoluer
le régime et le fracturer de l'intérieur
il est préférable dans notre intérêt
comme dans l'intérêt de la population
chinoise que grosso modo le la
croissance chinoise soit davantage axées
sur le marché intérieur chinois que sur
des rapines comme on a pu le voir au
cours de ces quarante dernières années
parce que le décollage de la chine
c'est en réalité une grande entreprise
de spoliation des classes moyennes et
des classes populaires occidental en
réalité l'histoire elle est très simple
c'est lénine qui nous a appris ça les
capitalistes sont tellement cupic ils
vendront la corde avec laquelle on va
dépendre
donc en réalité les capitaux se sont
déplacés du monde occidental vers la
chine pour profiter d'une survaleur avec
des salaires très bas et on ratiboiser
sous prétexte de vendre des produits les
cochonneries à bas coût de main d'oeuvre
dont ils ont inondé des classes
populaires ici mais d'un côté il leur
donnait plus de pouvoir d'achat en
achetant des choses moins cher mais de
l'autre on les mettait au chômage on les
paye avec des allocations et le trade
off est très simple aux etats unis c'est
les salariés pauvres ici c'est du
chômage et des aides sociales
mais dans les deux cas ça a fait le
bonheur du cac 40 et dont les deux cas
ça a fait écarter les revenus et
effondré
le pouvoir d'achat des classes
populaires courte faire gagner j'aurais
une dernière question
c'est ici des réponses courtes à ça à
cette course il fallait faire la
différence
non je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
analyse c'est cette histoire de
l'économie que que guillaume naud propos
je ne crois pas que le déclin relatif de
l'occident sous a dû à la chine
dire que guillaume résonne ici comme les
économistes de l'ancien régime qui nous
présente le commerce international comme
un jeu à somme nulle ce qui ne l'est pas
il n'y a aujourd'hui aucun lien entre
eux il n'est pas non plus il n'y a pas
de lien aujourd'hui entre l'exposition à
la concurrence chinoise et l'explosion
du chômage un pays comme la suisse qui
commercent qui est un taux d'importation
des marchandises chinoises qui
équivalent à la france des pays par une
poignée avec nos la suisse est plus
dépendante du commerce extérieur que la
france il ya plus interdit des paris
comme la théorie du droit durable au
japon comme singapour qui est
directement exposé à la concurrence tout
ça ce sont des économies qui médecin
grand bonheur ou 5 5 ha pour est un pays
qui importent beaucoup plus en
proportion de sa richesse des produits
chinois et pourtant qu'il dit salaire
très élevé un chômage inexistant
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas imputer
le problème à des causes qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir
en france les causes de notre stagnation
sons sont très facilement identifiables
en fait ça s'explique par un double
mouvement paradoxal de dire que tandis
qu'on a la chine dans une dictature
communiste qui à partir de la fin des
années soixante dix s'est partiellement
quoique insuffisamment rapprocher des
standards d'une économie de marché
l'occident prend le chemin inverse
depuis quasiment un siècle par un
alourdissement toujours plus plus plus
fort des charges fiscales et
réglementaires on est un pays non non
non c'est une fille est une conséquence
de nos préjugés de nos préjugés marxiste
et kohlberg liste on est un pays qui se
vendent bien avec nadal
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas un facteur de
localisation qui joue lens à la
délocalisation tous les pays développés
en ont connues simplement qu est-ce qui
fait par exemple un pays comme la suisse
ou singapour qui ont connu des
délocalisations et bien ont quand même
remplacer leur vieille industrie par des
industries à haute valeur ajoutée
c'est qu'ils ont une législation
beaucoup plus favorables à
l'accumulation de capital innovation que
que notre pays on est un pays qui se
vante de soumettre les classes
industrieuse à toutes sortes de
vexations réglementaire et fiscal on est
le
pis le plus taxé de l' ocde et ensuite
on s'étonne que les capitaux se barre et
ne viennent pas chez nous donc je pense
que ce salon se sont mêlés locale qu'il
faut déconstruire mais ce n'est pas le
commerce mais nationale qui aujourd'hui
incarne la vierge vierge vierge de tout
impact d'autonomie lecteurs il ya des
secteurs qui ont été fragilisés bien sûr
par le commerce mondial mais savez la
concurrence internationale pose les
mêmes problèmes que l'automatisation
évidemment que lorsque vous avez une
automatisation vous avez des secteurs
qui souffrent mais ce sont des problèmes
de court terme et pour autant c'est pas
parce que la révolution industrielle a
licencié des centaines de milliers de
paysans qu'on va qu'on va pester contre
l'automatisation et introduction du
tracteur mais c'est la même chose pour
le commerce mondial
c'est que vous apportez des trombes
d'eau à mon moulin parce que c'est juste
de la suisse de singapour de la corée du
japon sont des pays qui sont
économiquement très très nationaliste
alors oui c'est une c'est une c'est un
aspect des choses c'est vrai mais je
rappelle quand même sur l'explosion des
disons de les dépenses publiques est
directement corrélé à l'effondrement de
la croissance d'un côté et à la
compensation d'un mouvement s'est
inversé des causes et des transferts
sociaux sert qu'à partir du moment où on
a mis les gens à la porte
on leur a payé des tas de stage on leur
a payé des tas de chômage on leur a payé
à localiser
c'est le sytème de ressenti les extrêmes
jeu je vais arrêter le débat ici bon on
a compris vos prêts on peut le continuer
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a lancé également
on a compris que vous étiez contre la
guerre commerciale avec la chine et
guillaume était pour
pour faire simple oui parce que je pense
que ça va augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
des chinois et le repas et le rapport de
force en faveur des français peut-être
je voulais juste vous soumettre cette
phrase que j'ai trouvé très intéressante
dans le figaro cité donc là par isabelle
lasserre dans son article dans l'édition
papier du figaro d'aujourd'hui c'est
pierre vimont ancien ambassadeur de
france aux états unis ancien directeur
de cabinet de dominique de villepin
la logique est toujours la même
washington analyse où sont ses intérêts
se lance et veut voir ses partenaires
suivre
c'est la méthode américaine et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous a posé la question
sur twitter doit-on absolument s'opposer
à la chine à la suite des états unis et
vous répondez
eh bien oui à 54% et non à 46%
pourquoi on serait pas capable d'être
indépendant dit à linverse philippe il y
en a marre de voir constamment lécher
les bottes des grandes puissances
le mieux serait de s'allier à la chine
face aux états unis estime carrément
françois c'est intéressant ac c'est
c'est un débat ce n'est pas celui qu'on
a eues mais justement sur peut-être la
stratégie d' équilibre que pourrait que
pourrait avoir la france qui peut
s'allier bon mentalement une fois que
les états unis avec l'argentine joue
avec la chine
bon ça sera un autre jour qu'on aura ce
débat mais en tout cas je le
je vous le sou mais il faut être
partenaires globalement avec le pays
avec eux tout en restant vigilant au cas
par cas dans les échanges directs avec
des entreprises chinoises nous dit
nickel et chinois russes américains ou
français soient tous la liberté mais le
degré de liberté souhaité différentes en
fonction des pays et coutumes estime
diable off
rusty finger ironise très bonne idée
partons en guerre contre la chine
vu qu'il nous apprivoise but qui nous
approvisionnent en absolument tout dans
trois semaines on est mort nicole 06
nous dit finalement peyrefitte avait
raison quand il avait écrit son livre
quand la chine s'éveillera personne
n'arrivera à lutter contre leur
hégémonie
je vous propose nicole de regarder un
sujet qu'on a faits qui s'appelle qui
concerne justement la démographie
chinoise pourquoi la chine autorise
aujourd'hui la trois enfants par famille
peut-être que là on a justement eu une
faiblesse de la chine notre confrère
stéphane marchandises et ya une
quinzaine d'années dans un livre qu'il a
écrit que très intéressant la chine a la
hantise d'être vieille avant d'être
riche peut-être que c'est là également
que la chine a encore des des faiblesses
avant de se quitter je vous soumet ce
livre de clément fayolle ces français au
service de l'étranger c'est un livre qui
est très intéressant notamment un
chapitre justement sur jean pierre
raffarin et son rapport avec la chine
ou comment clément fayolle raconte nous
avons pas mal livrer tous nos secrets
industriels transfert de technologie à
la chine notamment ont construit sans le
fameux lead labo p42 one
ce qui est très intéressant également
dans ce livre c'est de voir combien les
élites diplomatique que dénonce
également guillaume bigot dénonce les
élites plus générale mais les élites
diplomatiques ont parfois des conflits
d'intérêts dans les
avec d'autres avec deux pays mais
surtout ce que ça révèle justement de
leur sentiment qu'ils ne croient plus
justement en la france et c'est
peut-être ça qui fait le plus froid dans
le dos dans ce livre et puis bien sûr on
recommande
justement guillaume bigot populo phobie
pourquoi il faut remplacer selon vous
guillaume la classe dirigeante française
et c'est aux éditions plon collection
tribune libre 1 une dernière annonce ce
qui me regarde en direct sur youtube et
on est merci beaucoup de le faire et de
l'avoir fait jusqu'à présent
alors un petit peu faire évoluer les
choses à partir de lundi vous pourrez
nous retrouver henry blessure sur
youtube et bien sûr vous pourrez
toujours continuer nous retrouver en
direct mais directement sur le site du
figaro alors on a mis la drees pour nous
retrouver en direct dans la description
youtube vidéos point le figaro.fr et on
vous y attend
vous venez nous voir en direct 2d lundi
à 17h avec guillaume requête patrick
peloux et laurent alexandre d'ici là bon
week-end et n'oubliez pas d'acheter le
figaro magazine
avec fabrice luchini a très vite sur
figaro life
[Musique]